yes the rocket saving the score 50
points in the paint because Adam
she gets the basket clenched down eight
points there's another basket
but in rhythm even with that miss he
looking better ruthless yeah that boy at
the inside of the rim so he just missed
sweeter to the basket for to
triple-double with the Rockets 146 in
his career
[Music]
and it's ruder with authority
back the other way River makes it inside
and 2 and don't look now but it's a 9-2
run by Oklahoma City yeah it's tough
because it happens to all of the
long-range shooters and there is
throated going to the basket for a layup
as you probably want to be worst state
House seats were target soja house to
the basket lays it up and missed it and
here comes OKC Gallinari says I got it
maybe capela put that in there on that
block they are the two that were that
and there's gallon Eric covering fellas
boy Rockets are 9 of 40 behind the
three-point line
their basket
Gil just Alexander three-point Houston
lead
[Applause]
Allen re-open again Gallinari hits again
32 points for Westbrook he's averaged 32
and a half last year games
[Music]
Bruner trying to stay with him James
just can't go anywhere
loses the ball he's Ritter trying to
stay with him games just can't go
anywhere loses the ball
[Applause]
[Music]
it's trail by three points something
they've been unable
trying to take it inside got it
one-point game
this time hard to score
boys pockets me the defense's stop right
here
[Applause]
screw into the ball hits the jumper off
over hard
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
much bigger muscala
back outside to rustle rustle
and find a place to get a shine now he
takes him three he missed it tip that
side
got five seconds left and the Rockets
have to fire
[Applause]
what I'm saying this afternoon what
[Applause]
a terrible game for the Rockets today
blowing a 17-point lead
very deflating as the fans
[Applause]
blackish player of the game presented by
cross bank russell westbrook 32 points
11 rebounds and 12 assists but the
rockets unable to shoot today 9 of 44
behind the arc
escort 41 points
with five seconds left and one the
Thunder went on a twenty seven to seven
runs pounds
mrs. shrewder had 15 points in this
quarter and Gallinari had 12 and the
worst defeat of the season for the
Houston Rockets the Rockets have now
lost five of their last six games